[Music]
right welcome back i'm using eggs but
some leftover rice to do a beautiful
fried classic rice the nasi goreng this
is a rice literally grown in west
sumatra and look at the grains the
grains are huge
okay and this type of rice is only grown
here
it's great for fried rice because it
takes on so much flavor i'm gonna fry
off the eggs first i've got some sambal
here and some sweet soy and a little
touch of the random paste start this off
again we all have leftover rice so this
is a lovely way of literally
turning leftover rice into
an amazing dish chili's galangal i'm
going to grate some of that over there
to sort of sweeten everything up and
because everything moves so fast you
need to be super ready so i'm going to
quickly just chop the chilis okay again
i want this to be quite hot the rice is
very starchy the grain is huge so you
need to sort of get some heat in there
over that i'm going to start grating
okay they're going to go i just want all
that sort of
juice and puree over those chillies that
will make it a little bit sweeter and
less spicy
put that onto my chilis that galangal
will help make that super sweet
chive blossoms at the end now these are
literally
almost like spring onions to you and i
get them ready okay that's give a nice
green light sort of oniony flavor
to the rice
but it's got a really nice dense sort of
spicy chai feel those blossoms at the
end have a little bit of kick in there
okay all the ingredients ready
okay because this goes quick
right
whisk your eggs
lightly color those yolks
beautiful touch of all
okay gonna be quick in here now get that
all nice and warm
okay
i want to sort of get that around
my wok
and just
literally get that what
get rid of excess oil
give that a nice wipe so it's nice and
sticky
okay fresh all in
i'm gonna fry off
all my
spices first okay
in
super cool
keep that heat in there
okay
and just lightly
cook them off okay
that softens
the chai blossom starts to cook that
incredible chili and that galangal puree
just lifts everything up makes this rice
super spicy from there lightly season
that
and now get your eggs in there okay
again eggs in
and start scrambling those eggs very
quickly i like to use a whisk so it gets
all broken up
so you can see it
cutting nicely
again as that starts to scramble
eggs are cooking
because that starts to cook let it set
and then break it up again
all right
change the wok
because super hot
i need a bigger wok especially for the
rice
now that egg is beautifully fried
a little bit more depth in my wok
to get my rice in
rice goes in
beautiful
now we start toasting that
and frying that
and mixing that
egg
and the spice in there
beautiful
keep that heat in there
and get that rice all the way up
into the center of the wok
okay make a little circle in the middle
there
okay
they'll touch our
samba in the middle fry that off
a little touch of the rang dang
i want mainly oil in there
get that literally
frying off
beautiful and then
once it's fried off i'm gonna start
mixing it in
with the rice
here we go now give that a good mix in
and
keep it nice and hot
now if you've got any fish or chicken or
even beef left over now's the time to
put in there but toast that rice okay
and the exciting thing about the rice
here from where sumatra is the fact that
it's almost
a large grain
really starchy
so it naturally thickens but i want that
texture that fried rice
and then i'm going to take a little
touch of sweet
soy just a tablespoon into the center
bring up the temp and then literally
fry it off there now though
[Music]
that's gonna literally give that
wonderful flavor
[Music]
[Music]
keep the heat in the wok
okay
[Music]
give that a really good toss
it stops the rice from sticking together
and then create the seasoning
finely
catch myself
thin
and then
away
beautiful
and then back
here we go
and that's beautiful
fried rice
now
that
is rice to die for it's fragrant it is a
classic dish and look
it's fluffy
it smells delicious and
wow
who needs a takeaway when you do it
yourself
let me know in the comments what you
think of that amazing dish and if you
missed uncharted trust me you can watch
it on the link below or on the nat geo
app
[Music]